تنبؤات بمزيد من الزلازل ترعب العالم
والكل يبحث عن الحقيقه والقبض على متعهدي
بناء في تركيا
مبانيهم انهارت بالكامل في الزلزال ومن
زيارته لحلب مسؤول في ميليشيا الحشد
الشعبي العراقي يعطي درسا في انعدام
الاخلاق والانسانيه اهلا بكم
الاسبوع الثاني على التوالي مشاهدينا
بنستمر معكم في نقل تطورات وتبعات الزلزال
اللي ضرب سوريا وتركيا الاثنين الماضي عزل
القتلى في كل البلدين تجاوز 35 الف قتيل
ومئات الالاف من الجرحى وملايين من
المشردين والهزات الارتداديه ما انتهت فمن
وقت الزلزال لليوم وصل عدد الهزات
الارتداديه اللي رسلت في تركيا بس
1891 هزه من بينها عدد من الهزات سجلت
صباح اليوم هذا غير عشرات الزلازل اللي
ضربت سوريا وتركيا وبدرجات قوه متفاوته
فسمعنا عن زلازل شرك وغرب ووسط تركيا
وزلزل على الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه وغرب
مدينه اللاذقيه السوريه واعلن المركز
الاوروبي المتوسطي للزلازل عن 500 زلزال
ضربوا مناطق حول العالم بتتجاوز قوتها
اربع درجات على مقياس ريختر ومن وقت زلزال
الاثنين الماضي وسيره كل الناس هي الزلازل
وامكانيه التنبؤ فيها فبدايه شفنا باحث
هولنديل وتغريده متنبئه بالزلزال واماكن
وقوعه قبل ما يقع بثلاثه ايام وبعدها
علماء قالوا صدفه وكذب والتنبؤ مو ممكن
ولكن رجعوا طلعوا علماء ثانيين وقالوا الا
ممكن التنبؤ فطلع الباحث الهولندي من جديد
يوم الجمعه في فيديو على يوتيوب وخوف
الناس اكثر وتوقع زلزال جديد كبير في
لبنان ومصر والسبب انه تاريخها البلدين
عرضه للزلازل الكبرى لكن اكد انه لا يمكن
التنبؤ بوقت حدوثه لكن اكيد الزلزال جاي
[موسيقى]
وكان
والباحث على فكره شغال في حسابات ردود على
كل من يشكل في تنبؤاته وبياكد انه التنبؤ
وارد وممكن غير الباحث الهولندي في علماء
كثير بياكدوا انه في زلازل جايه رئيس
اداره الجيولوجيين السعوديين الدكتور عبد
العزيز بن لابون في مقابله مع الحدث قال
انه في هزه ارضيه ممكن تحصل في بعمق البحر
الاحمر في اي وقت ورئيس قسم الابحاث
الزلزاليه في جامعه دمشق نضال جونيجا لانه
الفتره الراهنه بتشهد تفريغ تدريجي للطاقه
واللي يمكن انه يمتد لعده ايام وبيكون عبر
هزات محسوسه وممكن تنتج هزات ثانيه كمان
طيب ايش الحقيقه يا جماعه يعني
جايه المزيد من الزلازل هل حتكون مدمره
علميا فين الصح ايش المفروض احنا نعمل
فوست هذا كله خصوصا كم من التضارب
المعلومات الرهيبه اللي نحن صغيرين عايشين
فيه طيب احنا هينضم الينا رئيس الجمعيه
السعوديه لعلوم الارض والمشرف على مركز
الدراسات الزلزاليه في جامعه الملك سعود
عبد الله العمري اهلا فيك معانا
اول شيء خلينا يعني نحسب موضوع جدل التنبؤ
بالزلازل هل يمكن التنبؤ بالزلازل ولا لا
يمكن
قناه العربيه حقيقه
هذا حقيقه اذا كان دول المتقدمه واللي لها
باع كبير في هذا المجال الولايات المتحده
واليابان عندما ياتي من مساله التنبا
نهائيا اتجهوا الى ما يسمى ببرامج تخفيف
المخاطر الزلزاليه يصرفون بلين الدولارات
اليابان يحصل فيها يوميا سبعه الاف هزه
ومع هذا تنبؤ بالزلجال في الشمال الغربي
وقع في الجنوب الشرقي انتهى الموضوع
التنبؤ في علم الغيب اولا بعد اراده الله
سبحانه وتعالى لا يمكن التنبؤ بتبع ممكن
تتنبا بالاحوال الجويه ممكن الظروف
المناخيه لانها امامك
كيلو سرعه مختلفه جاذبيه مختلفه كثافه
مختلفه تركيب كيميائي تركيب فيزيائي حراره
ضغط مختلفه المعايير جدا مختلفه فبالتالي
ما تقدر حتى موضوع العمق الان موضوع عمق
البلدان مستحيل مرصد من المراتب اللي
تعطيك تركيا تقول
اقناعك يجيك بدولاء ايران تقول لك 13 كيلو
العمق يعني لا ثلاثه كيلو مستحيل وبالتالي
كيف تقدر تقولي هذا
متى التوقع نعم اتوقع زلزال معين في عالم
الفلاني بعد سنه سنتين هذا متوقع مثل ما
ذكرناه الخبير الهولندي صحيح كلامه لكن
اذا قال لك اتنبا معناه انا بحدد لك
الساعه الفلانيه بعد ثلاثه ايام او على
ضوء اعمال اخلاء
صراحه يعني في تغريد حدد الاماكن وقال
يعني ضربه حظ انت بتقول
شرق المتوسط عملنا منظمه تحت
اليونسكو ونجتمع سنويا عملناه الى الان
وكلنا بالاجماع كل سنه نقول الفالق البحر
الميت الين تركيا والاناث تتعرض لجلدان
عنيف كل مره بشكل ما فيها نقاط لكن ما
اختطانا نحدد متى يحصل هذا الزلزال طيب
نعم بالنسبه للتوقف
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للتوابع والهندسه الابتداديه صحيح
لماذا لان
الزلزال الثلاثين في الميه من الطاقه هذه
تتوزع على مدى ايام او اشهر او سنه حتى
تضمحل بالكامل وتنتهي بس على امتداد
الفارق اللي حصل عليه في البحر الميت
والتركيه وسوريا ما يطلع بعيد في المنطقه
نفسه هذا بالنسبه
للتوابع الزلزاليه
فاذا
تنبؤة الهولندي وحديثه عن انه هزت تصير في
مصر ولبنان او توقعه لهذا الموضوع يعني قد
يكون صحيح قد يكون صحيح
ايوه لا ما في احد يقدر
يقول لك والله ثلاث ايام
اقول انا اجاوبك انا اجاوبك نعم المنطقه
دي الان حتى تعرض البحر
قادم في خلال السنوات القادمه بناء على
ايه لان عندي سجل زلزال الى الفين سنه
للاردن وسوريا ومصر والمنكر بقدر احدد كم
الفتره الزمنيه الممكن يحصل سبع درجات في
المنطقه الفلانيه مثلا في اريحا حتى الان
1927 كان زلزال قاتل اللي فيها ايه
في سوريا حصل كذا في الخليج
هكذا
تتكرر تتكرر
لكن اقواها ترى في الشمال ليش في الشمال
لانه هناك ثلاث صفائح تلتقي مع بعض
العربيه واليوراثيه مع بعضها تاكيد
المنطقه اكثر عرضه من غيرها ثم تبدا تقل
اقل واقل جهه لبنان وسوريا والبحر
ثم لعرم ما في شيء ثم ترجع ثاني مره في
خليج العقبه وهكذا هذا
عفوا عفوا عفوا بعدين نروح الاقوى الاقوى
والاقوى جهه ايران جهه ايران منطقه اقتصاد
وفي جبال هذا
بالنسبه لرئيس اداره الجيولوجيين
السعوديين الدكتور عبد العزيز اللعبوني
اللي قال انه فيها هزه ارضيه ممكن تحصل في
عمق البحر الاحمر هذا الكلام ايش رايك فيه
البحر الاحمر
موضوع اخر البحر الاحمر لا يخضع للي حصل
في تركيا وهذا البحر الاحمر تشكل تشكل قبل
عشرين مليون سنه ثم هناك وتشكل في صدور
وفوارق والزلازل اللي في البحر الاحمر
وتحط سبعه لكنها ضعيفه لان الزلازل واقعه
في البحر الاحمر ناتجه عن عمليه شد وليست
عن عمليه تحول الشد غير مثل ما يعني كل
صفيحه العربيه رايحه
فاي جلج يحصل بقوه سته ترى يختلف عن
الدجال لو حصل القوه سته في تركيا تحت
الاحمر سبعه
ما في رام سبعه ليش لان الصفائح تتب
اعد فلذلك هذا كلام يعني مستبعد شويه
في البحر الاحمر بتاثير او يؤثر على
البنيه التحتيه في المملكه لا صحيح لو قلت
خليج العقبه اقرب لان خليج العقبه مربوط
بالبحر الميت لكن من البحر الاحمر شمال
وانت جايه جنوب هذا حد حد جرجاري مختلف عن
اللي ذكرناه انا اللي حاطه فيها مختلف طيب
خليني بس استفيد من وجودك معايا والوقت
والموضوع الهزات
والارتدادات والامور هذه كلها يعني من يوم
الاثنين هيئه الكوارث التركيه بتقول انه
حتى الان صار في 240 او عفوا 2040 400 بس
اذا اكدوا لي الرقم يا جماعه 2400 ايوه
بالفعل هزه ارتداديه يعني هذا الكلام
حيستمر لمتى وهذا مزيد من الدمار يعني
اللي حصل الله يسلمك خلني اصحح بنصلح اكثر
من كذا الارتداديه
ايش معنى حشود زلزاليه بالانجليزي
الرئيسيه توصل الفين ثلاثه
وخاصه وخاصه اذا كانت المنطقه فيها
بركانيه من اول فيها صخور بركانيه وخاصه
اذا عندك في تركيا السبب وجود السدود
والمنطقه مليانه بالمويه وجود المياه تعمل
استحساس وتعمل تحفيز للمنطقه للعديد من
الهزات لكن ليس لها تاثير قوي لكنها تقعد
تستمر تستمر لكن ليست مخيفه مثل ما حصل
يوم الاحد الماضي عفوا شفتي كيف فبالتالي
هذه حتى حتى تنتهي الطاقه وتنتقل من مكان
لمكه من شمال الاناظوري الى شرق
الاناظور الى سوريا الى مصر الى
لكن انتهي نهائيا والحدود اداه زلزاليه
وليست لحظه
ارتداديه الحشود غير
مثلا اعطيك مثل 2009 حصل عندنا الجردان في
حارات المدينه حاره العيد كان اربعه ونص
قالت له سته اشهر رصدنا 15
لاحقه 15 الف لاحظي اتمنى اي تاثير نسجلها
بس ما يحصل فيها المواطنين
وبالاسبوع الاول لان الزلازل الاسبوع
الاول
الرئيسيه بمقدار درجه لدرجة يعني هو بكره
يكون عدى اسبوع خلاص على الحدث بس
بروفيسور يعني انا حسيتك كانك بتحاول انه
تقول لنا انه يعني ان شاء الله خير ما في
شيء نعم نعم نعم
وحتى لو حصلت اي شيء
اقل المنطقه الاقوى هي اللي وقعت فيها
الدردال اللهم اجبر مصابهم اللي ايش لانه
حصل في خلال هذه المنطقه اللي انا تكلمت
عنها فيها خلال من 1939 الى امس حصل فيها
15 زلزال عنيف ومدمر
لاحظي يعني كل سنه يحصل فيها البلدان
المنطقه اللي هي
بالضبط منطقه منزميت وانت شرقا حتى تصيرين
المنطقه اللي حصل فيها عنتاب
الحمد لله
ولكن
الان الاردن وفاطين
بنفس القوه لا بعد ايش السبب لان منطقه
الاردن
فلسطين والبعض في منطقه البحر الميت عباره
عن الصفيحه العربي
وصفيحه سيناء تتجب فيها اللغه الجنوب
الغربي ما في تصادم ما في تصادم في
عمليتين احتكاك فقط
[موسيقى]
الله يسلمك وانا بشكرك على وجودك معنا
وعلى كل هذه المعلومات كان معنا رئيس
الجمعيه السعوديه لعلوم الارض والمشرف على
مركز الدراسات الزلزاليه في جامعه الملك
سعود البروفيسور عبد الله العمري شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
غير عشرات الالاف الارواح والاصابات
الزلزال كمان دمر مئات الالاف من الابنيه
في كل من سوريا وتركيا ورغم انه قوه
الزلزال كانت مدمره وعاليه جدا لكن في
كثير لوم وانتقادات على اسلوب البناء وعلى
المتعهدين والمقاولين خاصه المسؤولين عن
المباني الجديده واللي ما صمدت في وجه
الزلزال اطلاقا وطريقه انهياره كانت يعني
مثل كانها من خشب يعني وفي هذا الخصوص
السلطات التركيه يبدو بدات جهودا في
محاسبه هؤلاء وكشفت اليوم انها قبضت على
مقاول في غازي عنتاب و 11 مقاول في شانلي
اورفا وهدولا مسؤولين عن بنايات اتهدمت
بالكامل مو بس كده كشفت السلطات التركيه
كمان انه واحد من هدولا كان متعهد تجمع
سكني فيها طايب وتدمر بشكل كامل في
الزلزال وتخيلوا فيرمشكو في المطار جالس
بيحاول يهرب وشايل معاه مبالغ ماليه طائله
وعلى الرغم من انه في ابنيه انهارت بشكل
كامل في ابنه فضلت صامده ومصاب شيء مثل
مبنى المهندسين المدنيين في قهرمان مرعش
اللي كانت من مراكز الزلزال هذا المبنى
اللي تم تداول صور له وسط الحطام بعد
الزلزال وما صار في اي ضرر حتى الزجاج ما
انكسر والناس صارت تتوقع انه هل هذا يا
ترى بنائه بمعايير هندسيه عاليه ومقاومه
للزلازل ولا ايش هل لانه مبنى مخصص
المهندسين يعني فرحوا وبنوا بضمير يعني
كيف نجم من الانهيار وحتى الزجاجه ما تكسر
لكن رجع ناس كمان تداول وصور ابعد شويه
وقالوا مو صحيح انه المبنى الوحيد اللي
صمد وانه في غيره كمان على فكره صمدوا ومن
الحديث عن انعدام ضمير متعهدين ومقاولين
بيسترخص وكانوا في البناء وسببوا كل هذه
الخسائر بسبب طمعهم شفنا نوع ثاني من
الطمع اعجب واعجب وسرنا نسمع قصص عن سرقه
مساعدات للمتضررين من الزلزال فشفنا مثلا
فيديو الاعتقال السلطات التركيه لشخص كان
يدعي انه مشرف على مساعدات دوليه وبياخد
المساعدات ويحطها في مستودعات ويبيعها
للناس في سوريا برضو سمعنا وشفنا قصص عن
سرقه مساعدات غير سرقه المساعدات كمان في
ناس وسط كل هذا الدمار جالسين ينهبوا في
البيوت والمتاجر المدمره هذول اعلنت
التركيه عن القبض على ثمانيه واربعين منهم
في ثمانيه
وتوعدت بملاحقه الباقيين ايضا
[موسيقى]
وغير انعدام الضمير المتعلق بالبناء او
النهب او السرقه شفنا مقطع الانعدام اخلاق
وضمير من نوع مختلف تماما من القيادي
بمليشيا الحشد الشعبي في العراقي لسابع
لايران عبد العزيز المحمداوي الملقب ابي
الخال او ابو فدك السيد الفاضل هذا هو في
زيارته لمحافظه حلب يعني قال انه يعني ضمن
حمله مساعدات بيقدمها الحشد يعني
الزلزال في سوريا خلينا نسمع بالله ايش
لقطته الكاميرات وهو بيقول
يعني المحمداوي الضابط اي وحده متاخره او
فاتها القطار بتمشي عندنا
واحد مو عارف صراحه ايش يقول يعني بعيدا
عن الازمه الانسانيه والكارثه والزلزال
والموتى والناس اللي يعني حوالينه تحت
الانقاض بعيدا عن كل هذا الكلام اللي قاله
كارثه لوحده بكل المقاييس يعني فكيف في
ضمن السياق اللي اصلا الوضع العام في كله
وايش بالنسبه للابتسامه اللي على وشه يعني
في وسط هذا الدمار ولا ضحكه اللي حوالينه
على النكته اللي ما حتى نقدر نوصفها
بالبايخه لانها يعني مقززه ومقرفه حتى
يعني في يعني يعني لها اوصاف تانيه كمان
اسوا بكثير يعني الصراحه شيء مقزز فعلا
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نحن وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا عدو القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]